I'm Doug Chang I'm the vice president
and executive creative director for
Lucasfilm I'm Madeline Burkert I'm Lucas
Films collections and exhibitions
archivist and today we're going to talk
about every clone trooper instructure
birth as in the live-action Star Wars
films and yes we do mean every choice
[Music]
Imperial strong trooper those are one of
the most fascinating designs for me
because that was the first image that I
saw from Star Wars and the idea for that
was that George wanted to create these
sort of iconic imagery that looked like
living skeletons and that's why you have
the stark black and white and so when
you see the white armor coming out of a
black room you just see the armor and
it's a great terrifying sort of moment
for you especially when I was 15 years
old when I first saw that and one of the
iconic things was that the helmet is
very specific looks like a skull it's a
stylized skull and Ralph McQuarrie did a
brilliant job to take all the key
elements like the eye sockets in the
mouth to make it just sort of a touch
mechanical but yet still harken back to
a living skull initially the original
trilogy stormtroopers were made in such
a way that they were sort of geared
towards actors that were around five
foot ten to six feet to be able to fit
into the armor they were built out of
vac form plastic when it came time to
fit Han Solo and Luke Skywalker into
their disguise stormtrooper armor it
took a bit of magic from the costume
department to make them fit but they
were able to do it I can't think of a
film
Zann trooper they are the same design as
a stormtrooper armor but they're
modified to look a bit more suited for
the environment in which we see them
which is at first in a new hope back to
me joy distinguishing parts of this
costume are partly the backpack that
they wear the backpack was created out
of found objects from just like a local
hardware store so fans have spent many a
year trying to recreate those backpacks
in order to figure out what exact parts
of those components are made out of this
and troopers also distinguished by a
shoulder pauldron the shoulder Paul's
room was originally a piece of
motorcycle protective gear that were was
worn for for youths in the 70s and so
that piece actually very well suited
this this costume and one of the things
I love about the sand
troopers is that you get to accessorize
the classic stormtroopers and those
little touches actually adds so much
personality and character to a
stormtrooper outfit
space trooper well the majority of their
armor is the exact same as a
stormtrooper they are distinguished by
breathing apparatus on their helmets so
some of the some of the pieces on the
helmet are slightly different to adapt
for that they have a backpack that
provides ammunition Joe Johnston who was
a concept artist and very heavily
involved in the design process for the
original trilogy Star Wars films he
actually played the two Space strippers
that you see in a new hope they were
able to use some photographic magic to
make it look like there's two but really
it's the same the same actor wearing the
same suit TIE fighter pilots are it's
just a slight variation on your classic
stormtrooper pilot and the idea there
was just to take the classic armor the
white armor and turn it all black and
give them a helmet and then we actually
are utilizing the breather adapters in
the front of the helmet those are always
designed in there because these are
supposed to be zero-g outfits so you can
actually breathe in space and so we
actually see those hose connections
being used the apparatus that we see
attached to the chest armor those are
all also meant to evoke the same design
that you would see in terms of like the
Death Star bridge or the control panels
they wanted to make it sort of
emblematic of the Imperial ships at that
pilot first time that we see the outer
drivers in their vehicles is on the
Battle of Hoth in the Empire Strikes
Back
the helmet is derived from an original
stormtrooper helmet and a TIE fighter
pilot helmet design as well as the chest
armor pieces originally were TIE fighter
pilot pieces that were then repainted
and repurposed in order to accommodate
this new vehicle the the 8080 or that
snow troopers from Empire Strikes Back
or one of the designs than the variants
that I found really fascinating the snow
troopers obviously are in a heavy snow
environment so you have sort of this
facial shroud and they have more padded
clothing just you know for warmth but I
think iconically
it creates a very interesting silhouette
the components that you're able to play
with the backpack that implies that more
gear and as well they they have a
slightly different arrangement of
components of hard armored pieces to
accommodate the fact that it might be a
bit more difficult to move in this
environment
the first time that we see the Imperial
rail guard is in The Return of the Jedi
they are the guards for the Emperor I
mean pretty alright guards are a
stunning statement in terms of you know
who are these people and I think the
idea of choosing to go with a bold red
and kind of make them very mysterious so
that their face looks kind of very
exotic in that you don't know who's back
there is that a droid or is it a person
and I think the overall silhouette is
very powerful as these mysterious guards
for the Emperor
bright red is meant to provide a stark
contrast to the set design but it's also
kind of an homage George Lucas was very
much a fan of sort of classic hot rod
cars so this cherry red is definitely a
color that was influenced by his love of
those cars biker Scouts are scout
troopers are particularly suited for the
forest environment in this case the
woods of Endor their components are
designed as such that they'll be a bit
more comfortable suited sitting down as
well the location of their pistol which
is the first time we actually see a sort
of small handheld sidearm pistol on a
stormtrooper that pistols actually
mounted in into their boot I love their
helmet design because we were trying to
lean in to sort of biker iconography and
the idea that the mouth actually near
the snow became an open mouth almost
like an open scream
kind of created sort of a an emotional
look that's very terrifying the helmets
designed for practical purposes was also
designed to wear the face lifts up as
they learned on set trying to situate a
full stormtrooper helmet with seconds to
go before the camera starts rolling this
was a bit easier for the actors the
clone troopers were first introduced in
Episode two
attack of the clones for the clone
troopers none of them were actually
built practically there were all CG
characters that was a really fascinating
design explosion because George wanted
to connect bola fit with the classic
stormtroopers and he was leading up to
the fact that a stormtroopers were going
to be clones in this time period we were
keeping all the angles very sharp and
very stylized to kind of evoke sort of a
more romantic time and so in designing
the helmet itself we leaned into
designing a variant sort of a blend
between the classic boba fett helmet and
the stormtrooper helmet and that's why
you see the strong tee visor we retain
the mouth but we stylize that so the
helmet itself of the clone trooper
you'll see the evolution to the classic
stormtrooper unlike the classic
stormtrooper armor which is
traditionally white for all the
different stormtroopers the clone
trooper armor is distinguished by rank
based on different colors and color
patterns and schemes that are
implemented into the costume design red
denotes captain yellow denotes pilot or
commander green denotes sergeant and
blue denotes lieutenant phase to clone
troopers the style and the look of
different stormtrooper helmets over time
definitely evoke the societies in which
those clone troopers in this instance
come from we meet a lot of the clone
troopers during order 66 order 66 is
when Palpatine orders the disruption of
the Jedi execute order 66
[Music]
one thing that differentiates the clone
troopers from Episode three form the
ones in Episode two is the clone
troopers are asserting their
individuality their costumes have
different colorations and patterns they
are named characters which is not
typically how we differentiate different
stormtroopers from each other yes thank
you for example commander cody was named
after commando Cody as an old serial
that George loved and I loved those all
those little elements you know sort of
bringing things from George's
inspiration to sort of his films and so
this is one of those highlights for me
that makes me smile Pilate in looking at
the clone trooper pilot we see some
elements that definitely are going to
slowly evolve into what we now know as
our original trilogy by fighter pilots
the advanced recon trooper is kind
of an interesting look we're taking all
the key elements of the stormtrooper
helmet and now we're really stylizing
and trying to create a very aggressive
personality in the face a TRT driver his
costume is suited for his environment is
a sort of army green camouflaged look
and base shield
Elite core Clone Trooper and these were
primarily seen during the Battle of
Kashyyyk you're starting to see a blend
of the classic stormtrooper with a scout
trooper in terms of that open-face
scream and they wear eight distinct camo
look to fit the environment Galactic
Marines the face mask on this one
reminds us of the snow trooper from Hoth
during order 66 this clone trooper is
responsible for killing ki-adi-mundi
beloved Jedi
the five-o first Special Ops clone
troopers fought alongside anakin
skywalker as they attacked the jedi
temple in episode 3 revenge the imperial
shock troopers were part of Palpatine's
guards and they were colored bred we
first see them on Khorasan alongside
Palpatine after order 66 Buda pal
airborne Clone Trooper you can start to
see further evolutions of the helmet now
we're starting to blend a little bit
more of the scout trooper along with the
iconic shapes of the Vader mask the 327
star core clone troopers are
distinguished by their their yellow
elements in their uniforms they wear a
skirt which we will see later on in
future Star Wars stormtrooper designs
the core cyclones troopers are denoted
by their grey markings and they're
primarily used the defend Coruscant
first order stormtrooper the updated
design is not only updated take on the
stormtrooper armor that we know and love
but the technology in which the costume
effects Department enlisted in order to
create these physical costumes was
incredible achievements compared to the
original trilogy the original trilogy
while using back form methods to create
plastic armor the first-order armor was
primarily created using 3d printing
methods and also molded polyurethane
casting and molding to create incredibly
valuable pieces of armor the first
Nordic stormtrooper you'll notice we're
actually taking the next evolution in
terms of stormtrooper design really
stylizing the black and white features
of the down from mouth and also part of
the personality design idea was to make
these guys really kind of brutal very
strong very powerful there are lot of
many design considerations and
challenges one of the first thoughts was
how do we evolve the stormtrooper the
classic stormtroopers into the next
generation and we approached it by
really thinking about new materials what
would the new materials affect the
design and that's where you start to see
sort of the cleaner lines the cleaner
edges and you start to really understand
that okay this could be a next evolution
of the classic stormtrooper partly based
on design decisions and also based on
advancing construction methods the
helmets between the force awakens first
order stormtroopers and the forced order
stormtrooper helmets we see in the last
job I have slight variations the bridge
on the helmet nose is slightly narrower
in the last Jedi versions of these
helmets the first order stormtroopers
were really evoking a lot of the
historical elements from the classic
stormtroopers and by that I mean we're
actually kind of implying that these are
kind of going back to the original
genesis of the stormtroopers but yeah
updating it with all new materials
captain phasma we're trying to take the
evolution of the first order
stormtrooper and elevating to a higher
rank and we did that by changing the
material turning her into this amazing
chrome look designed by Michael Kaplan
JJ Abrams named Captain phasma after a
phantasm that a horror film where there
was a scroll ball that was very menacing
initially this character was meant to be
cast as a male character once they
decided to have this be a female actor
they didn't make any adjustments to the
costumes the custom that Gwendoline
Christie wears as Captain phasma it
still has the same amount of strength
evoked and wearing it however it's still
clear that a woman is wearing the suit
captain phasma's costume in the last
Jedi is visually more chromed than the
costume that we see in the force awakens
and part of this is because her ability
to be shot on camera in Episode seven
through to be very challenging because
often times lightning and cameras would
be shown in the reflections of her
costume and so to combat that it's a bit
duller machine by episode 8 Industrial
Light and Magic was full and ready for
the challenge of handling that amount of
Chrome on her costume and it was much
more effective to have the costume
visually appear to be much stronger in
China the first time we see the first
order flametrooper
is on jakku when they are attacking the
village the first order flametrooper is
are distinguished by their backpacks
that provide power for their flame
rifles that they carry first-order riot
control stormtrooper the first time that
we see this riot trooper is in the force
awakens where he is well known for being
a stormtrooper that yells traitor this
character carries I'm very menacing
baton as well as a riot shield the first
order stormtroopers were much more
likely to have individuated skill sets
and tasks so in this instance this
particular stormtrooper is outfitted in
this case weapons that most effectively
help him to do his duties
the first order mega blaster
stormtrooper is distinguished by the
ammunition packs that he wears over his
chest armor as well as a very large
heavy heavy blaster the first order snow
troopers were a next evolution of the
classic snow troopers that we saw in
Empire Strikes Back you'll see that we
preserve the veil that covers the mask
and we kept the overall silhouette and
the only thing we really updated was
just to give them a little bit more mass
to make them a little bit more powerful
looking the first order of type pallets
we kind of kept the same idea where we
took the classic first order outfit and
just made them black and then for the
special ops version we gave them red
stripes and that's the kind of mirror
the red stripes that we see on the TIE
fighters the Imperial assault tank pilot
is one of those designs that's one of my
favorite a sneeze sort of the stylized
look at the stormtroopers and we kind of
refine the lines and you'll see that all
the elements are there but they're very
clean
many of the armor pieces on this costume
are actually the same exact pieces as
you see on the shore trooper this mask
was designed by Glenn Dillon he and Coe
costume designer David Crossman created
this helmet design that sort of saw a
bit like the death trooper has this
mandible effect to it to give it a bit
of a menacing look
I mean Tyrael death troopers were a new
class of stormtroopers and we first see
the best troopers in road one alongside
director chronic we want to design them
so that they were sleek and powerful
more like the SEAL Team six of
stormtroopers and we distinctly made
them larger than life so they were
taller than six feet and we also decided
to keep them brain narrow so they look
like very athletic and that they could
move very fast one of the singling
factors of the death troopers is the
mask and we spend a lot of time
designing that and ultimately we ended
up with this very aggressive look were
the side cheeks actually almost became
like mandibles so I gave it a very
slight of menacing spider-like
personality the Imperial shore trooper
we first see these in row 1
their roles are very present in battle
and Skara they are distinguished by
three different looks that denote their
ranking so there's the short trooper
captain there's the short trooper squad
leader and there's the soldier but the
colors that they wear the blue
definitely evokes the ocean and the
water that they fight alongside in scare
off' and then the beige color is sort of
meant to match the beach fighting these
costumes were designed to fit the
environment very much like the scout
troopers they have less armor and more
soft fabrics and also you can see a
little bit of scout trooper in the face
mask the first time we see the
executioner troopers is aboard the
supremacy flanking captain phasma in the
last Jedi the first order executioner is
distinguished by black markings and he
also carries an electoral laser axe
the first time we meet the Praetorian
guards is in stokes throne room in the
last Jedi the elite Praetorian guards
have three different helmet variations
their helmets and their weapons are
coordinated their costume design is
meant to show that there are at the
ready but that they are also able to
move flexibly they're sort of evoking a
bit of a samurai style actually my
favorite scene in the last Jedi is when
Rey and kylo Ren fight and defeat all of
the Praetorian guards in snoke's throne
room
the MinMin stormtroopers the uniforms of
the men men stormtroopers are meant to
suit and and look and fit into the
environment in which they fight which is
the min bin battlefields but they also
have a cape to help with that and then
with their helmets has an added lip on
top that distinguishes it from a regular
classic in Korea my troopers we first
see the stormtrooper in solo those were
an interesting design where we were
trying to go backwards and time a little
bit from the classic stormtrooper and
the idea was that these troopers were in
a very dirty mud filled environment so
we want to make them look very gritty
costume designers Glen Dylan and Dave
craftsman used elements of World War one
soldiers that were fighting using trench
warfare tactics to help design and
inform the look of this costume and much
like the trench warfare during World War
one the these mud troopers were
outfitted with similar types of combat
gear that you would have seen in World
War one for instance their gas mask
evokes that as well we also see Han Solo
wearing a version of this uniform while
fighting in Minden and his is a bit
different from others in that we
actually see his face because we're
meant to see Han Solo because we need to
know that it's thick the soldier and kid
you don't want any part of this
Imperial Patrol trooper we perceive on
Corellia in solo and you notice in the
design we're actually starting to now
blend even more scale trooper into the
look so the whole outfit is a little bit
more soft fabrics and then the face is a
blend of the classic trooper with the
sculptured Bergman range troopers is
during the train heist in solo and what
distinguishes them is the magnetic boots
which allows them to actually clamp it
to the exterior of the Train the actual
practical build of the boots includes
light up it has some hydraulic
mechanisms in there that actually emit
steam and this is to give that full
effect so that as we see it practically
shot the boots will definitely give you
that illusion that they're magnetic
first time we see the first order jet
troopers are on pisano the jet troopers
jet pack is actually part of his armor
and we see other elements that are meant
to evoke this sort of fast-moving jet
propulsion characterization that this
trooper armor has there's actually an O
Maj to an original Ralph McQuarrie
production painting on the insignia on
the chest plate we first see that in the
first order stupor
but then costumed artist Glenn Dillon
decided to add a version of that
insignia into this jet trooper we also
see the mandible design returning on the
helmet
now the first time we see the first
order tread speeder driver is in the
rise of Skywalker the first order tread
speeder it combines elements of a first
order stormtrooper armor pieces along
with a sort of further evolution of the
biker Scout there's a soft pant element
as opposed to thigh armor to make it so
that this stormtrooper is better suited
to writing a new version of a sort of
speeder bike this is a first-order
electro prod stormtrooper we first see
them in the rise of Skywalker fares are
noted by the fact that they have a new
weapon the electro prod the sister pert
is a new trooper for the rise of
Skywalker if we think about the white
stormtrooper evoking a skeleton the Sith
trooper is meant to evoke kind of the
muscles kind of the internal strength
that you might find in a soldier much
like the death troopers if it's quite
close to the body it's meant to evoke
the fact that this is a stormtrooper
that's you ready for any anything that
comes at it one of the interesting
aspects is that you'll notice in the
helmet we're bringing back some of the
elements of the Clone Trooper with that
strong sort of nose tee visor look the
six jet trooper it combines elements of
the Sith stripper and the first-order
jet trooper that we see in the rise of
Skywalker there's a jet pack that's
connected to the back armor of this
trooper and as well as that sort of
mandible effect on the helmet and that
was every single clone trooper and
stormtrooper in the live-action Star
Wars films and that's it for now but we
can't wait for you to see what's coming
up next
[Music]
you